how I hey how's it going my name is
Pierre loti back then welcome back to
[ __ ] hell what the hell we went down
this elevator I think this will be the
last episode isn't a trial whoosh ah la
Fitte you scared the [ __ ] out of me shy
well can I just talk to you like a
normal human being
no I would never [ __ ] you you will never
what they don't lately no [ __ ] let's
read this I'm scared
well you're not alone [ __ ] not only for
my life wait anonymous identity okay but
the lives of everyone around me earlier
today we excavated what seemed to be
complex circuit to be accomplished
legibility system beneath the belly with
foolish she ventured into them without
the hesitation after an hour to one of
those triple dot things attacked us
triple dot it was like the corpse I
found the other day except this time it
was alive it killed them to a lot it
killed them all triple dot I just ran
covered in their blood I somehow managed
to escape on harm but was it even worth
it
I can't take this anymore I'm scared
what if those things find their way out
of the mines and into the village what
then they must be demons I'm sure of it
I must find a way to stop if they came
from here then what the [ __ ] am I going
here for answer me
don't ask me actually oh [ __ ] this is
actually really [ __ ] goosebump
worthy it's fine I have a hammer and oil
don't you dare come near me
don't you dare
Oh nine minutes long Nelson's going back
behind why did it Elisabet go without
him just a little bit further okay yeah
it's kind of creepy it's for the
ceremony
you're supposed to dress up nice it's
such an important ceremony wise and
Simon coming yes it doesn't like a
creepy man the ceremony's about you
remember yeah but I still don't
understand
they go on in sacrified Elizabet parody
don't you get it hammer I don't get it
but it doesn't matter alright kids on my
dad it's kept going good
I'll protect depends you know what
that's what happened so far
well that [ __ ] hammer didn't help
what do I do I don't want to play oh it
was a pro fire it was a [ __ ] pervert
you son of a [ __ ] hammer you son of a
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] [ __ ] me that's fine at
least I have oil now I had oil before
[ __ ] and the owner to have a hammer I
don't need you I don't need you in your
lies but parents I'll protect you all
I'm your friend oh [ __ ] hey I'll gladly
[ __ ] here I [ __ ] a lot of women but
I'm not a woman god jesus smegging mags
and cows in here a cogwheel I don't
doggedly need that [ __ ] huh okay night
night night we're going this way it
seems I was just gonna
how about what the [ __ ] are you doing I
was following your pity just making sure
you're okay all right [ __ ] this caveman
have a tap it requires a key I have a
master key doesn't worry okay well it
looks like we should go here right ah
wait where did I come from
I came from here tonight yeah okay you
confuse me [ __ ] die again
ha ha I win bids know you don't know
your [ __ ] note
never alright shovel don't scare me
again where the [ __ ] am I so here I
really feel kind of [ __ ] loss I'm sure
there's something nice in here didn't
that's where I came from
what is this storage what okay this is a
lot bigger than I thought that's what
she said haha not funny so all jug pads
you always make amateur jocks pound at
our tire Dada
well um I don't even know that's just to
make it cozy
uh-huh a demonic sacrificing circle
wonderful I'm starting to realize what
happened to Elizabeth now that's
clutches that intelligent beings as long
as I keep provide providing them with
sacrifices they stay on the ground and
don't harm me I put together a small
group consisting of me William and a few
others trusted individuals I am leader
and I told them that this must kept busy
lap that them that bismuth kept secure
the valence would never approve of my
actions but I know I'm doing the right
thing it must be you didn't do the right
thing I have a confession ever it pains
me doing misses but after somebody
sacrifice and alls become soothing the
smell of their blood the sound of
rippling fresh maybe this is just a sign
that fate wants to commit continue this
is my destiny
you done deadly [ __ ] if why do I keep
saying it like a lot of books here cool
well hello Cindy you're relating a black
lovely
stay calm stay calm stay calm and run
the [ __ ] away from there
what suggest a trap or ah [ __ ]
I think I have to go here that's the
thing where the [ __ ] did he go
I need that key hello boiling you were
hiding there I see you ma ma ma ma
you've been better than battles okay
I'm never gonna [ __ ] me to get out of
here alive sir doesn't really matter
what I do
oh this is just [ __ ] disorienting man
bros I'm so [ __ ]
oh look at that beautiful did you draw
that don't care hey Lada
Oh lovely lovely lovely lovely
what Oh a string I could use that to
pull in my butt what is that I never see
you before shovel huh you're working
with the bowels I know it okay yeah well
[ __ ] hey fun cool La Porte
Oh more pork okay Bowser gunshot whoa
whoa the [ __ ] da da da not daughter Jase
it's [ __ ] cries man all right what do
we got
oh let's use a string here kids a genius
doesn't [ __ ] work
[ __ ]
the pipe looks like it repaired recently
well then smash it oh sure sorry sorry
that was anything what the pipe looks
like it no I repaired it is that it let
me let me wash my genitals feels good
okay what do we do now
no why did I do that I must have some
reason for doing that done diddly double
there what stop saying that
well [ __ ] right Jennifer [ __ ]
good I'm glad you know what's coming on
it please I'm glad someone has it has a
[ __ ] on the [ __ ] racer
well I guess we keep looking then
xiaocui I'm just scared this
[ __ ] will Oh another door hello
hey what's going on here
oh cool I could have been in the one
level increase but it still need a way
to search the key oh oh that's where the
string comes in oh you teleported eh oh
machine room key you see that [ __ ] down
oh that's right Christopher I
accidentally dropped the key to the
machine room in the game but I don't
even need that [ __ ] I'm too [ __ ]
smart for all your [ __ ] right we
gotta go back all the way that's that's
the biggest problem for me not to solve
the puzzle to find the way back I think
it's on the hey yes quite nice and a
night
Xzibit happy now
manolo back don't look at him [ __ ]
backing it's fine it's fine it's fine
inside that's fine that's fine
I mean I think I [ __ ] don't even know
how to use doors stupid oh it really
[ __ ] scares me Nang Phung daughter
okay to commit god damnit this angry oh
I'll just go there now or don't you
think I'm gonna get scared of you again
you little [ __ ] Jesus ba ba ba
I mean bad alright alright so again you
[ __ ] traitor
but tears out don't literally waiting
for don't talk to me like that
Jason okay then machine room key Oh son
let's close this locked [ __ ] I would
barricade it if I could
can I can I barricade that [ __ ] I can't
barricade with anything
[ __ ] oh
haha you think I gotta go in there you
go
I'm not going no I know it's not gonna
be good in here I don't wanna
okay we're fine I'm fine I did it
identify
big debate day yeah that's it does it's
good that is good yeah
my man that [ __ ] I'm a pasta solving
genius now what what I do exactly gets
get poked her defense by the night
weather what add wet Wow well only wakes
months wow what the [ __ ] I don't even
know anymore
hello hello what is there something here
now someone they jump over that oh look
at that look at that I slide over like a
snail I don't know what I just did but I
think I liked it it's not a song
no that's the way I like okay well [ __ ]
um okay uh you can come out now
uh I did it I don't know what I just did
well let's keep going anyway
da da da da da da da da da da
Wow
I think this is what I didn't go the
last time because that [ __ ] [ __ ]
scare me oh hello this is the exit
perhaps I don't even know dad and mother
okay this is where I got jump-scare uh
poof scared or whatever the [ __ ]
okay serious kids focus come on man what
are we doing here I'm just glad my Latin
so loyally that sounded really gay
Latin still oily alright it uh I turned
off the machinery but - why why did I
turn off the machinery can I go up again
place that's a one-way ticket huh
she's pure scatter ticket to rock ah
Pierre scatter ticket ah ha ha dudes
gotta to get a ride and shovel is there
yeah I shake up with me shovel shovels
got a ticket - ah ah yeah shovels got a
ticket to rock ow
shovels got a ticket her ride and Pierre
- you scared
uh-huh that broad break it down till we
girls rub dub stick mix it
Popovich launched a bone on bone chapel
boom cool it when a pairs it sells part
the machine now they run a pairs I maybe
I missed something I don't even know
haha
that is night good fits quite maybe
let's read the notes [ __ ] is this
no not you what the [ __ ]
but I don't like this my new shoes are
all wet now [ __ ] man
whoa that was me well the cam is
preventing me from uh pending result
what okay we'll go here oh this thing is
probably on before I didn't see you
hello sir hello don't you dare don't you
forget about beards dad pick up pick up
your dippy I don't even know anymore the
little tag not go out with all my BAM
I'm gonna take your head and a rabbit of
my god my heart